Who leaked them. Why were they leaked?
How many secrets were lost?
These are the key new questions
this morning.
As the Pentagon scrambles
to do damage control
after a highly classified documents
surfaced online.
CNN has reviewed 53 of these documents.
All of them appear to have been produced
between mid-February and early March.
Some reveal how the U.S.
has been eavesdropping on
key allies, including
South Korea, Israel, Ukraine.
A source close to Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelensky tells CNN.
Ukraine has already altered
some of its military plans
because of these leaks.
CNN national security reporter
Tasha Bertrand joins us now
live from the Pentagon to Tasha,
what are you learning about
where these documents came from
and how the administration is responding
John, it's really remarkable.
What we are learning
is that these documents
first appeared
on a social media
platform called Discord Discord
at least a month ago.
And there are at least 50 of them,
which CNN has reviewed,
and all of them have classified markings,
including some
up to the top secret level,
which is the highest level
of classification in the US government.
Now.
The US
Department of Justice is investigating
the matter
based on a referral from the Pentagon,
which referred
the matter to the Justice Department
and the FBI for further investigation
on Friday night.
But look, these documents contain
incredibly sensitive information
about Ukrainian troop
movements, strengths and weaknesses,
including weaknesses
in their air defenses.
As well as really important
and new information
about just how far the US
intelligence community
has been able to go in penetrating
the Russian Defense Ministry as well.
As the Russian mercenary
organization Wagner Group,
which of course
is also carrying out operations
in Ukraine.
Now, we are also learning
from these documents that this comes
this information
in these top secret
documents come from a variety
of different agencies across the U.S.
government,
including the CIA,
as well as the Defense
Intelligence Agency.
And so this really has
impacted a lot of different agencies
across the government,
as well as many of the United States,
its closest
allies, including Israel and South Korea.
A lot of these documents detail U.S.
eavesdropping
and intercepted
communications of these foreign allies
talking to each other.
So obviously,
there's going to be some friction here
moving forward between the U.S.
and allies.
They are already, though,
talking to those allies
and conducting a damage assessment,
John, of how this leak may impact
national security.
Natasha Bertrand, extraordinary stuff.
Thank you so much.
Keep us posted.
And Kate,
I have to believe
there's a great deal of concern
because the leaker
could still be out there.
That's exactly right.
And you're
talking about kind of the scope of where
this leaked information came from.
Let's dig into a little bit more of what
what is being revealed
in these documents.
Many of the leaked documents,
as Natasha was talking about,
deal with Russia's war
on Ukraine,
including intelligence on both countries.
One secret document from February.
Details the diminishing missile stocks
that Ukraine has on hand
and also includes estimated delivery
of additional weapons systems
and the training plans
for Ukrainian soldiers on those systems.
Now, another document shows proposed
military strategies
for Ukraine, logistics
and policy recommendations
for the country, for Ukraine.
Yet another document
and it's marked top secret.
It contains information on Russia
and Ukrainian battalion sizes
and their locations,
as well as the level of battlefield
casualties being suffered on both sides.
U.S.
officials believe that the losses
spelled out in this document
in particular
may have been altered
to show fewer Russian casualties
than estimated.
Other documents show the extent of U.S.
spying operations
on South Korea
and Israel,
including with relation to South Korea.
A conversation between two senior South
Korean national security officials
about their concerns over a U.S.
request for ammunition
that would be sent to Ukraine.
Those officials discuss a way
to get around the country's
policy of not supplying
lethal aid to countries at war.
And when it comes to Israel.
Some of those leaked documents
have sparked outrage in the country.
Intelligence gathered allegedly
revealing that Israel's
own intelligence service from Assad
has been encouraging protests
against the country's new government.
The prime minister's office
has already come out and flatly denied
that assessment.
Now, joining me, there's a lot in here,
but joining me for much more on
this is Lieutenant General Mark Hertling.
Mark Hertling, CNN, military analyst.
General,
we lay out
just some of what is being revealed
in these documents.
What's most problematic
about these leaks from your view?
Is what you said just a minute ago, Kate,
is most problematic.
There's a lot of them
and they're across the board.
But what also adds to it,
it's different than past leaks.
Which have been,
you know,
documents like the Snowden leaks
that we the WikiLeaks
that are documented,
pieces of paper that did tell the story.
What these do
and what we've seen some of them do
or perhaps
give misdirection or disinformation.
They have been
redesigned to show different things
from the original documents.
We know that already.
So it's a combination of real live data,
real life
secrets, as Natasha Bertrand said,
you said there.
Some of them are cops secret,
but on some of those documents.
So it's a top secret.
No foreign,
which means there
is no foreign dissemination.
That's the marking
that's at the top of those.
So it's not only the kind of intelligence
we collect on phones,
but also the kind of intelligence
that all nations connect,
collect on their friends to.
We do this. Other nations do it too.
But you don't like it to be
put into the public space.
You're hitting on something
that I wanted to ask you about,
because if you're
if we're putting in perspective, it's
one thing if intelligence is leaked,
never a good thing.
But if intelligence is leaked
about a past program or a broader
strategy or operation,
what we're looking at here in the sense
that we're getting
in the reaction to it is
what does it mean
when it's in real time, general,
when the leak has to do
with supply levels
and capabilities in an ongoing war?
Yeah, again, I'll
compare it to the WikiLeaks
a couple of years ago that occurred.
Those were cables
and things that were going on
between embassies
and had long term planning issues.
But when you're talking about today,
the Russian invasion in Ukraine,
our intent
to support our Ukrainian partners
with equipment
and with supplies
the battle maps that are happening,
you know, within the last week
or the last couple of days,
you know, those killed real live close in
a timely intelligence to an enemy.
And that's not good.
It's unfortunate
that this has happened this way.
But it's also truthfully, Kate,
being risk misread
by many people who don't understand
what's in those documents.
And I'll say The New York Times
did a piece yesterday
where they literally
put two slides from the Joint Staff
within their article
with no description of what it was.
You know, when I read it,
when I looked at the two slides,
having been on the Joint Staff once
I knew exactly what it was saying
and it was not saying the same thing
that was in the newspaper report.
So you're going to get amateur
intel analysis
analyst
saying things that just aren't true
about some of these documents,
but that doesn't
decrease the the the fear factor
that's involved in these things
leaking to the general public.
General, real quick, what does U.S.
military need to be doing right now
to mitigate the damage from that?
Yeah, fine.
Fine. Who leaked it, first of all?
And they've done that by addressing it
with the Department of Justice.
But there's also some internal looks on
how these things could have gotten out.
I have some ideas, having
worked in the Pentagon.
What might have happened.
But they also have
to do really rapid assessments,
not only the U.S.
military,
but also militaries around the world
and governments around the world.
They have to pull intel analysts
off their normal job,
which takes them away from what
they would normally be doing and say,
hey, what's the damage
assessment of these things, linking
what could happen?
Because people see
what's on these documents
or know about the sources and methods
all of those things are important
and all those things are.
This is obviously happening as we speak.
General, thank you
very, very much, Sarah.